let's talk about the the retail adoption
right in terms of there's a lot of
technologies in the space that are
fairly deep in the weeds right when it
comes to how does the tech work you know
what can we solve some of the
scalability issues etc and I think that
they probably are not thinking as much
about how do you drive adoption of that
mass consumer right I think you
mentioned that there's gonna be some
financial products and things like ETFs
that could potentially help you open
those gates to crypto what has to happen
on the UX side to make it easier for
kind of that mass consumer to not use a
retail financial product like you know
an ETF etc but still get much easier
access to buying holding and transacting
Bitcoin yeah so I think a lot of that UX
actually does exist right in really good
ways I think coinbase
you know despite all a lot of their
foibles has done a pretty good job of
there I think Square has done an amazing
job I actually think Square has now the
best experience for using and working
with Bitcoin but I think that the a lot
of the you know when when people say we
need more user adoption or growth
they're often focused on the usability
of products that interface with you know
with crypto currencies and I actually
think that that's not the sort of main
bottleneck I think that the harder
problem is actually you know shifting
the narrative right it's explaining and
educating investors whether their
institutional whether their retail on
what the merits of a non-sovereign money
system could be right and I think from
their branching into and exploring you
know well what are other forms of money
that could exist beside so a crypto
money that could exist besides Bitcoin
what is the path to monetization of
something like ether etc but it's I
think all of that is grounded in an
education campaign more than an actual
usability exercise I think what we've
seen in the past especially in the last
retail run-up is that a lot of the
emphasis was around
retail investors trying bastis what I'll
describe is the next Bitcoin which I
find is pretty misguided effort you know
but we saw ripple run up substantially
we saw you know yes and ether run up
substantially and I think what was couch
and we saw Cardinal run up substantially
especially in Asian markets where it has
very broad-based appeal I think that all
of these users are looking for something
that is better faster cheaper has a
higher transaction throughput etc than
Bitcoin right I think that that's what's
driving a lot of retail interests
because they think that they can capture
something that is meaningful a better
than Bitcoin on those axes and I think
that that approach is actually totally
misguided I don't think it makes much
sense I think that what that reflects to
me is actually that users don't
understand the value proposition a
Bitcoin right they might be buying
Bitcoin that won't be holding Bitcoin
they might even be using Bitcoin but I
think that that education campaign is
kind of the first place to start is is
teaching all investors institutional or
retail what the value proposition is a
Bitcoin are what the history behind
cryptocurrencies is and kind of where
you know sort of value can can accrue
and be captured long term